how would you like to party with Hallie
in Vegas once this pandemic is over
listen it could happen in you know what
Pauline she's ready for the break
because listen to what she told me
about life in quarantine it's a
nightmare for me it's a nightmare and
they're not learning anything to get
them to focus and realize they're at
home but yet they're at school it's it's
really been a challenge we have been
making good use of the time when they're
not in school when I'm not you know
fresh cracking the whip for school we do
have a lot of family time so there is
the silver lining how he's home
isolating with 12 year old daughter Nala
and six-year-old son Maceo her little
man is clearly a comedian with big shoes
to fill you know that's what you got to
do in these times you got to find the
fun I just found a work up I could do
with my son I use my son as wait it's
fun for him and then I get I get a
workout too and the 53 year old super
strong mama is also giving back she just
launched a free fitness app filled with
home workout ideas called re spin she's
also joining Chris Pratt Justin
Timberlake and the cast of friends for
the all-in challenge she and UFC
president Dana White will auction off
the ultimate MMA Vegas weekend with
Halle you and a guest get the fly out to
Vegas you stayed three nights in a
four-star hotel you will go to dinner
with Halle Berry then the next night you
will sit at the fights with her in my
seats you can literally put up $10 and
you can win this thing I challenge you
and everyone at et you create a batter
challenge together good luck good luck
with that by the way we're on it do that
a hundred percent of the money that is
raised goes to feeding America challenge
accepted and by the way she worked her
butt off playing an MMA fighter in her
directorial film debut called wound
I got to train about four hours a day
for almost six weeks those ABS are the
real deal halli even broke some bones
during production hell you got hurt -
you gonna get hurt if you get kicked and
you haven't built up that muscle memory
to take those kicks yeah - acting not a
real fighter like another bruise popped
up another pues and then finally some
bones with and you know that's how it
went you try it up like five three okay
you scream and hit the ground Kevin
that's what you do birds
[Music]